foreign
that went viral and this is
um this is a warning video
and um I got I shared this on the Ken
Coleman show earlier today and this this
could be relevant for a lot of our
listeners and viewers so let's play it
then we'll comment on
a day in my life getting laid off at
Google so I woke up to this really
ominous text from my boss and I honestly
had no idea what it was going to be
about so I called her the minute I woke
up and saw this and she told me to check
the news and my email so I rushed
downstairs to find out that I had lost
access to basically everything I
couldn't log into my email or even check
my calendar I called my boss back and we
just sobbed over the phone because she
was also finding out about my layoff for
the first time today too I started
getting calls from a bunch of my
co-workers and started finding out who
else was let go on my team and some
neighboring teams as well but I think
the worst part is that it seems like no
one was consulted on this decision and
everyone was just finding out about the
layoffs at the same time it just felt
like a really bad game of Russian
Roulette and there was no consistency
around who was let go it was also not
Performance Based so it just felt really
random okay so there you go now in the
news it came out on Friday of last week
George Google laid off about 12 000
employees which is about six percent of
their Global Workforce this is across
product areas functions different
product areas functions levels and
regions according to CEO Sundar pakai if
you say it that way I think it is I
think I'm Hooked on Phonics uh that this
is a result of Google hiring too quickly
and couldn't keep all its staff on the
current economic reality but here's why
I showed that video on the Ken Coleman
show why we show it here George
anytime that you hear a talk of
recession and we're seeing a larger
companies laying off people more
announced more expected to be announced
this week a lot of tech companies laying
people off and this is happening more
and more
this is a young lady
who finds out about the layoffs when she
sees the news and she wakes up she calls
her direct leader who says well let's
get online and figure this out together
I don't know if if you've been laid off
or not she goes downstairs to get on her
laptop and is subsequently locked out
she finds out I've been locked out
overnight and so her her direct leader
did not even know that this young lady
had been laid off now
how does that hit you well from what I
read I saw a piece that was saying hey
folks didn't know if they didn't check
their email the night before they showed
up to work and there was just a line of
people checking their fobs and that's
how you figure out that's how you feel
you can get in the door you're still
employed no it's a terrible way to go
about it now folks the reason we share
this is if you were at a company I don't
care how large or small and you don't
have a sense
that the leadership values you as an
individual not a unit of production then
you need to start paying attention
because leaders like this and this is
Google and they think they're too big
for it to really have a negative impact
on them but I'm going to tell you
something they aren't too big to fall
and this has been a wave of just social
media testimonies about them doing this
I've got a Business Insider article
right here in my hands
and one engineer shares a story of being
at Google for 20 years
an engineer for 20 years and he was laid
off via email
no face-to-face conversation
here's a couple more
this is this is the worst
uh another guy
um
says that he went in at 4am
this is Dan Russell research scientist
said on LinkedIn I found out when I went
to work at 4am to finish up an important
analysis and my badge didn't work
the guy's going at 4am to work and his
badge doesn't work 17 and a half years
at Google gone Elizabeth Hart a senior
Marketing Manager on Google's Global ads
team
uh said she woke up early Friday morning
and saw a notification
that her corporate access had expired
along with an email with the New York
Times link to the article about Google
laying people oh man so Google is big
enough Savvy enough to know that they're
gonna have to lay people off there's no
excuse
for not having a real person sit down
with them eyeballed eyeball knee to knee
and explain what's going on and have
some sense of compassion but let me tell
you what it is George it's about a
checklist we got to lay off 12 of our uh
12 000 people six percent of our
Workforce we don't have time to do it
this way this is how we're going to do
it and you know what we're Google we'll
just get another batch of young people
coming out of college and and I'm going
to tell you something this is eventually
going to catch up to companies well you
lose the guy who had 20 years experience
and you hire the guy who's just jumping
into this thing well you make a very
good point not only do you lose him you
treat him so harshly
that he leaves with a bunch of
institutional knowledge that you don't
even know what he's what he knows and
what he's taking with him it's bad
business forget bad human behavior it's
bad business Behavior so all that to say
well in these publicly traded companies
can
a lot of them are just beholden to the
shareholders that's 100 stock price
whatever they got to do to make the
shareholders happy and therefore people
become a unit of production which is sad
so you want to know why there's an
anti-work movement why is that this kind
of nonsense
you treat people like they aren't humans
you treat them like they are just a
number on your spreadsheet they start to
believe that
you know like quiet cleaning is a
phenomenon because of crap like this
leaders not valuing people
and when you would just keep treating
people like units of production you
don't care for them you don't treat them
like they've got a heart uh like they've
like they've got emotions then uh you're
gonna have a revolt and this just
continues to happen so we're going to
shine the light on here at Ramsey
Solutions because
um we care about people here we care
about our team we care about you and you
can work in a place that values you you
better get to one of those places
because I'm telling you if you're not in
a place that values people even if they
have to lay you off
okay uh in a place where they care about
you they'll treat you well um that's
true and thankfully Ramsay has never had
to lay anyone off in the history of this
place which is pretty amazing and it
speaks to how much they value people so
just bad behavior so can a lot of people
I see on their LinkedIn it says you know
hashtag open to work what do people do
in a case where they were just laid off
or they could potentially be laid off
any minute what would you suggest they
do on the career side okay well first
thing is this is a this is a really
rough rejection so you need to grieve
this you need to understand that while
it may not be personal it feels personal
so let's let's go get it out of our
system friends family members if you
gotta cry some fine you know the point
is let's own it that it sucks that it
hurts and then after we've gotten that
out of our system that it feels that way
we've got to then step back into reality
that it does not hurt your future a lot
of people have been laid off people get
laid off all the time and there's still
a lot of opportunities and so you get
back up on the horse and the way you do
that is I'm going to make connections
connections connection connections I
hope that you have connections laid out
way in advance you know when you get on
an airplane and the flight attendants
come in and they tell you in case of a
water landing here are your exits you
need to do the same thing if you work
for a large company if you work for a
company that may be struggling
financially you don't know what could
happen so what would an exit strategy
look like if a storm came you know I can
see you in your new home I bet you have
a storm shelter and so you got your
flashlight you got your batteries you
got your water I'm going to John eloni's
house if something goes down that's not
a good idea because he's just going to
put you with the chickens that's true
but the idea is okay who are people that
I know in my industry that are really
well connected
um what is a part-time or an Uber type
job that I could could take on our two
part-time job you might have to swallow
your pride and go what do I need to do
right now to bring it in well this gets
back to George you and what Dave and
Rachel teach about the budget if I know
my four walls budget then what are some
jobs that I know that I could probably
go get pretty quickly that take care of
my four walls that's what I mean by
having an extra strategy that's
temporary
until maybe I can then get back into the
industry that I want to be in that's the
idea it doesn't have to be a crisis we
want it to be a nuisance big difference
I like that so the emergency fund yeah
being debt free and having money in the
bank it changes a layoff drastically
yeah oh yeah because now it's annoying
and frustrating but it's not devastating
so man uh really pulling for all those
folks that are getting laid off around
the nation and it's a wild time we are
hoping the best for you you can jump
into a new career and Ken's advice is
spot on this is not the end this does
not define you it will refine you if you
let it